yeah hello welcome everyone thanks a lot
for joining today I would like to
introduce you to bivalent domains and
give you a bit of an introduction of
what we know about them and what still
are open questions in the field I will
begin by introducing some key players of
Bavarian domains and talk about what we
understand about them in mechanistic
terms I will also touch upon how new
Tozawa symmetry and valency are related
and finally in the end we will discuss
some open questions and future
directions of the field actually the
velum domains and the intersection of
many different fields so all of these
fields will probably deserve their own
ready now so I would like to apologize
upfront to all the lapses important work
I will not be able to cover today so
let's start with some basics and to
probably all know the basic unit of
chromatin is the nuclear zone it
consists of two copies each of the four
core histones h2a h2b h4 and h3 in all
these systems can undergo many different
pol sensational modifications and some
of these modifications contain
information about the expression status
of a gene it can mark them as either
being on or off in this way histone
marks at the centre of development they
reflect developmental decisions but also
shape the directive trajectory of a cell
on organism down a developmental path
that is also very much - for the two
modifications we will focus on today one
of them is histone h3 lysine 4
trimethylation and the other one is
histone h3 19:27 trimethylation
k4 trimethylation is a so-called active
market is founded promoters of active
genes whereas k-27 is an inactive or
repressive life
refine it at promoters of inactive genes
and also gene bodies of inactive genes
these modifications are installed by big
multi-subunit protein complexes in the
case of k4 trimethylation these are the
said one and ml l1 into protein
complexes they have one main catalytic
subunit and a number of additional
subunits that help them with their
catalytic activity and with their
targeting
in the case of k-27 trimethylation we
have only one complex that is
introducing this modification it's the
polycomb repressive context - or short
PSC - it has one catalytic subunit in
the h2 or in the h1 another isoform and
again additional auxiliary supplements
that are required for activity as the
name suggests these complexes are very
important for development they have been
identified in flies where mutations in
them need to correct characteristic body
patterning defects hence their names
Polycom and try for x so we know that
these complexes are very important for
development presumably so are their
marks and one setting where they could
play a role in development are the
bivalent domains these were discovered
over a decade ago now by two different
labs the lab of Eric Lander and the lab
of Amanda Fisher and they were analyzing
chromatin States and embryonic stem
cells and to do that they use an
approach called chip chromatin
immunoprecipitation which I would just
like to briefly introduce with the chip
we can pinpoint where specific
modification for instance the inactive
mark or the active mark are found in
chromatin and that's the first step we
have to break down chromatin in little
pieces and we can do this by other
sonication or by enzymatic digest and
then we use an antibody against the
modification we want to study and do a
pull down or immuno precipitation with
it and then all the fragments that
contain this modification are purified
we can then isolate the DNA from the
chip tear from the chip chromatin and
sequences and in this way pinpoint where
specific modifications like the
skateboarder methylation here or another
modification like k-27 trimethylation
are located in the genome and this is
exactly what both of these these labs
did and here's a figure from the
Bernstein paper where they use these
blocks to indicate where these marks are
present and then we go next emcell p.m.
they found for these two genes and many
others that you have both k4 and K 27
time escalation signals for the same
side that was not the case for several
other cell lines that they studied and
then a follow-up study
they studied this on a more genome-wide
level and also for different cell types
for embryonic stem cells neural
precursors and mouse embryonic
fibroblast and they found again that for
many different genes all of which were
developmentally regulated they see both
k4 trimethylation NK 27 trimethylation
being present at the same place at the
same time this is true for the embryonic
stem cells but not so much for the more
differentiated cell lines so if we look
at this again at housekeeping genes in
embryonic stem cells we were precursors
for mouse embryonic fibroblasts we
always have a peak of k4 trimethylation
as one would expect for an active gene
at the developmentally regulated genes
there's both an active mark k4 and K 27
the inactive mark in embryonic stem
cells in terms of expression these genes
are either lowly expressed or they're
completely turned off from
differentiation to neuro precursors
certain genes like this neural marker
gene or laQuan are being turned on they
are being expressed and then they have
only one of the modification and it's
the active one in the cell line that is
not neuronal this gene will be shut down
and will only have they were pressed
with K 27 trimethylation line so based
on these observations the hypothesis was
formulated by these labs that this
pabellón domain configuration made poi
genes for expression in other words it
keeps them lonely expressed in the s
holds that keeps the ready to be either
activated or repressed during repression
and as I mentioned this was ten years
ago so for now for a decade we already
have this hypothesis present and the
field has put in a lot of effort to
either prove or disprove the hypothesis
and I would like to convince you that
yes we made some strides towards proving
and further and thoroughly testing the
hypothesis but there's still a lot of
open questions and I would like to
discuss different aspects of the
hypothesis I would like to sit this in
different parts and yeah let to begin
look let's look at the easiest one which
is well if bivalent domains are supposed
to pause streams for expression during
development they should occur mostly in
cell lines that have developmental
potential
and that was fairly clear already from
the beginning so to go back to the
Mickelson paper they found about two and
a half thousand promoters that were
bivalent meaning they had bulk a 401k 27
in their gypsy data in embryonic stem
cells from differentiation to new report
roses most of these two and a half
thousand genes they resolved to either
the only k4 trimethylation or k-27
trimethylation only very few of them
actually state by Venom's so that would
make sense for a developmental
regulating paradigm you have a lot of
these in embryonic stem cells but not so
many in Europe precursors the Shabalala
employed similar assays to test this
question they use the stepwise
differentiation protocol that they
started from embryonic stem cells going
to through neural precursors to tell a
differentiated pyramidal neurons and
they also monitored by their own domains
in the setting
they also found about 2005 nm domains of
embryonic stem cells and they observed
as well that many of them resolved
during differentiation meaning they end
up with only having one of these two
marks but not both at the same time
however interestingly in the analysis
other genes also became bivalent that
means they are not a static one-way
street meaning they are bivalent in
embryonic stem cells and then only can
resolve during differentiation but no
other looks I can also become by Venom's
and the same happens from
differentiation to terminally
differentiated neurons most of the
dependent domains are lost but again a
few are gained in addition to embryonic
stem cells at this new approach Anytus
bivalent domains have over time been
observed in many different systems these
include induced pluripotent cells at
advanced stem cells and other types of
adult stem cells like humans creating
stem cells they are also found in cancer
cells in terms of autoimmune isms we
know that they exist in mammals
meaning mouse and human systems for
instance but also in zebrafish people
have worked very hard but they couldn't
find any by variant domain so far in
Xenopus an end result that we suggest
that these organisms probably employ
different ways to poison
another important question is well he
fell off sale and so this is all nice
and fine but for these violent amends to
play role during development in the
living organism would be nice to be able
to detect them in living organisms and
Peter Gunn attempted deaths during his
time in general sampler by looking at
cells isolated from embryos and
analyzing them straight after isolation
and he looked at the NSL mask which
usually decides to embryonic stem cells
and indeed again found after 2000 genes
that can be classified as bivalent
because they have both k4 trimethylation
and k-27 trimethylation in ship CSS that
were optimized for the low cell numbers
that he obtained however they will know
the venom domains in cell lines that
comparison to the trophoblast lineage or
to extra embryonic tissues and it became
apparent pretty quickly why that is the
case because these are tissues they do
not have a lot of k-27 trimethylation so
they are depleted in this inactive mark
lettuce because they lack most of the
supplements of the PSU 2 complex however
despite the absence of k-27 translation
they still have another repressive mark
which is canine trimethylation and as
they were able to show in truffle brown
stem cells and as well as an extra
embryonic tissues canine ty methylation
can probably functionally replace k-27
feminization their developmental genes
are marked by both k4 trimethylation and
canine trimethylation this indicates
that there's perhaps a different flavor
of event domains as well not only the
ones that have k4 and K 27 but also the
ones that have k4 and k9 v appellation
whether these are functionally
equivalent we don't know yet and this
remains to be seen so we can say yes my
venom domains are definitely found in
cells and tissues that have
developmental potential and that would
be in line with their proposed function
a next question would be well are these
two marks actually present at the same
place at the same time and well from the
data we looked at so far we just assume
that this is the case
however if gypsy gases are performed and
signals are observed for both K 4 and K
27 this observation can be explained by
a number of different things first of
all this could simply be due to the fact
that the cell population we are
analyzing is not homogeneous it's
actually a heterogenous having cells
that have either one mark or the other
such mixing effect can also come from
other things for example one of the two
alleles could have the k4 trimethylation
and the other one could have the K 27
proclamation however if we think that
these are actually doing something
together and poison genes you would
expect these two marks to be present at
the same place
it would mean they would have to occur
in all the cells together at the same
degree so there's a bunch of different
ways of how we can test that one of them
is what we could try to avoid this
heterogeneity in stem cells one way of
doing that is by using the so-called two
eye conditions which put cells embryonic
stem cells in a ground state pluripotent
state these two inhibitors involves the
PD compound which blocks map kinase
signaling as well as the carbon compound
which inhibits GS k3 and thereby
activates beta catenin
and windsaver alone and this feeds into
the coral pluripotency circuitry and
thereby these cells are in a very clear
potent State and show very different
flag to Asians and gene expression and
morphology between each other so this
way we end up with a very homogeneous
population and the stolen red lab and
others as well have used that to analyze
the velum domains and very homogenous
populations so what you see here these
plots are promoters that are aligned by
their transcriptional start site and
then plus from minus x 2 plus 5 KB the
intensity of a specific bar is being
plotted and this way we can easily
visualize many different promoters if
you look at the active mark that its
distribution is very similar between 0 &
2 eye positions however if we look at
the repressive mark we see very striking
differences between 0 & 2 i there is a
redistribution of k-27 trimethylation
why that is the case
we will not go into that right now and
we will just look at the consequences
for bivalent domains that this has so
they under several conditions also
observe develops 3005 in domains which
mostly overlapped with the ones that
came out of the makers and paper however
under the valent conditions two-thirds
of these are gone they are not being
scored as the vent and more because they
don't have an overlap of k-27 and k4
anymore that is high enough to make
these lows I qualify as prevalence
however they're still about a thousand
left that are bivalent in this very
homogeneous population so this tells us
two things one thing is yes by venom
domains also exist in very homogeneous
cell populations however from this data
we also get a very strong caveat there
are a lot of false positives in this
analysis which probably arise from mixed
cell populations so whenever we see list
of the vendee genes it's always there's
always a possibility that they are false
positives in there which come from
mixture of cell populations and cell
states so this is one way of looking at
the coherence of these two marks another
way is to do this for a specific gene by
using a sequential chip or WeChat
approach in sequential chip we are doing
is instead of looking at one
modification and then the other in a
single chip I think we enrich first for
one modification for instance the k-27
trimethylation mark then use the purify
material separated from the antibody and
then probe for the presence of another
mark in this case k porter methylation
and here in the original Bernstein paper
they have done exactly that for one
sample gene and this gene here are X 2
where the transcriptional start site has
both marks actually these marks are
present at the same place at the same
time because we can enrich for both
marks in a sequential ship and
importantly this has also been done in
freshly isolated cells in this paper
here where sequential chip was done for
K for channel 4 NK 27 trimethylation
and these developmental genes here show
a signal for both
these modifications so take them
together we can say yes these two marks
many cases occur together at the same
place at the same time however we don't
really know what conformation they adopt
and there's a bunch of different
possible confirmations give that all
these edits were done on sonicated DNA
info chip which usually spends multiple
different nucleosomes we can have these
three arrangements the first one is that
these marks coexist on the same piece of
DNA but they actually are different
nucleosomes and they're just adjacent
one nuclear zone is marked with the
active mark and the other one is marked
with the repressive life another
possibility is that these marks actually
occurring on the same nuclear zone
together one way of achieving that is by
having both modifications present on the
same histone however there's another
possibility to introduce both
modifications within one nuclear zone
and that is by having one modification
of one tail and the other modification
on another tail as a postdoc with Dan
wrangler and tried to resolve these
three confirmations and to do that we
made model nucleosomes from embryonic
stem cells monitor consumes means we
used an enzyme to break down chromatin
into fragments that correspond to
exactly one neutral zone so all the
modifications that we detect on the
histones they must come from one looks a
zone so what we did was we took these
monitor prisms and purified them with an
antibody level specific for k4
trimethylation so all material that we
obtained only as the k4 trimethylation
mark either on one or on both copies of
h3 and then we were able to use mass
spectrometry to analyze the core
appearance of other histone
modifications and we did this together
with the lab of Ben Gaussian so if we
look at these neutral zones that have k4
trimethylation and then look at what is
going on at k9 we see that at k9 there
is very little dye and trimethylation
and that is to be expected because these
logs are repressive marks and they
should not be present on access the
motors
unconscious we saw a lot of acetylation
present together with k4 trimethylation
that is also what one would expect
because k9 acetylation is also a
hallmark of active promoters when we
look at k-27 Trello surprise we observed
that we have both k-27 die and
trimethylation presence together with k4
trimethylation so that is very strong
support that both bivalent marks are
together present at the same place at
the same time because we can't detect on
the prisms that have k4 trimethylation a
significant amount of k-27
trimethylation we can further convert
confirm this with sequential chip essays
on these mononuclear zones where again
we know both modifications must be
present on the same which is known and
we selected a few control genes that are
active in housekeeping they are only
marked with k4 trimethylation but not
k-27 trimethylation we selected a few
Bevan genes as well they have both the
k4 indicate 27 trimethylation of the
single chip and then if we do the reed
trip and first look at K 27 translation
and then k4 trimethylation we see that
we only get a signal for the ones that
are prevalent and not for the
housekeeping ones so we can confirm that
both of these confirmations in principle
can exist we can have the a symmetric
configuration with both modifications at
present together on the same liquid zone
or we can have also the symmetric
configuration here where we have both
modifications on the same nucleus own
but also on the same pistol there was a
lot of information also based on mass
spectrometry that this is very unlikely
to occur to have both k4 and K 27 on the
same histone so that would leave us
primarily with this conformation here
which however leads us to a bigger
question and that is Lucas's almost
symmetry the nucleosomes is a very
symmetric particle it has a symmetry
axis here in the middle and both of
these h3 copies here at least in the
globular domain cannot be really
distinguished because of the symmetry
axis and it was commonly assumed that
the symmetry also extends to the histone
tails
other words if a modification is present
on one tail it should also be present on
the other one better ever has never been
tested experimentally and again as a
pollster with Danny Weinberg I tried to
address this question and to make a long
story short we actually we're able to
extra mentally show that nucleosomes can
be both symmetric and a symmetric if we
look at the repressive k-27
trimethylation mark it can be present in
a symmetric configuration on both
histones within the nuclear zone however
it can also be present in an a symmetric
configuration where we have it on one
but not the other tail and it turned out
that this asymmetry is crucial for the
establishment of evident domains because
we found that bivalent mutism actually
also have an a symmetric configuration
they have k4 trimethylation on one
histone and k-27 trimethylation on
another histone in one of the reasons
why that is the case is linked to the
catalytic properties of the PSC to
complex PSC to is inhibited by the
active capable chemical ation mark but
only if it's present on both copies of a
histone if it's only on one copy of a
histone within the nucleosome PSC 2 is
still able to modify the other one and
then establish the bivalent state and
very recently our mass spectrometry
based work was covered over was
confirmed by the Bernstein lab by using
a completely independent approach what
they did was they also took cells and
made mononucleosis from them and
purified them then they used DNA that
was biotin labeled and fused that to the
nucleosomes and this way they could then
immobilize these we presumes to copy
slips that were coated with step evident
and this gives them a nice surface to
use fluorescently labeled antibodies to
use single molecule fluorescence imaging
to detect the presence or absence of a
modification on a given realism and in
this way they were nicely able to
confirm the existence of bivalent new
prisms where one nucleon has both
modifications at the same time they
looked at the occurrence of the single
modifications in embryonic stem cells
and a few other cell types and then
we're also able to detect both of these
occurring together by giving both the
green fluorescence on the active mark
and the red fluorescence on the
by yielding this yellow spot Hume and
for embryonic stem cells these were much
more highly represented than what would
he expect from just random co-occurrence
of these two modifications if they were
randomly distributed within the genome
then they took this a step forward
further to analyze the symmetry and
asymmetry relation and what they did was
they took these nuclear zones and broke
them apart and then labeled the single
histones and again immobilized the
longest and evident coded coverslips
and then looked at the occurrence of the
different modifications on the single
histones and they were very similar to
what we found in the mass spectrometry
approach they realized that you almost
never have k-27 and k4 present on the
same histone so that means that the vast
majority almost all of the bivalent
nucleosomes must be in this a symmetric
configuration with one modification is
of one tail and the other is on the
other not only very few of them will
have this symmetric configuration and
very interestingly they then took this
yet another step further by looking at
the DNA that was wrapped around these
surveillant a symmetric nucleosomes they
stripped it from all the histones that
were bound and then made use of a
synthesis of a sequencing by synthesis
approach and sequence the DNA that was
bound to these nucleosomes and that
works reasonably well you get good
coverage when you compare this to
previously established data by
chip-sequencing so they can map to the
genome where by variant lucre zones are
and unfortunately the depth of the
sequencing is not quite there yet but we
have some very exciting for us snapshots
of where we have a symmetric bivalent
which results within the genome and i'm
sure there will be very fast
developments in this region and we will
finally be able to tell where bivalent
nucleosomes are sitting in the genome so
taken together we can say yes clearly k4
trimethylation in 27 time acylation do
occur together at bivalent domains
however just as a caveat to keep in mind
they might also be false positives that
need to be excluded for analysis and one
way of doing that is by doing sequential
chip
we know that this momentum configuration
at least in the vast majority of cases
is a symmetric we have k-27 on one tail
and k4 on the other tail within the same
neutral zone that we only very rarely
have this configuration where we have
both modifications present on the same
histone so now we know that these two
marks are there together at the same
time but how do they get there in the
first place and that leads us to the
very broad field of polynomial trade
Forex protein recruitment I just want to
highlight a few principles here the very
beginning it already became clear that
one especially one signal is important
for the establishment of event domains
and these are the so called CPG Islands
these are regions in the genome of about
1 KB that are very rich in the dinin
Cleo type C gene and all these forbidden
domains here that were found in the
initial studies they all have but CPG
Islands at their promoters so people
tested how significant the CPG Island
signal is willing for the establishment
of event domains so the team around that
Bernstein Val dated is they took DNA
from a coli which chorus which has
properties of CPG islands in the valium
cells but obviously has no relation in
terms of sequence and does not contain
any known transcriptional activation or
repression signals that would be found
in mammalian DNA and just by introducing
these pieces of DNA that have so-called
CPG Islands from eco line there was
enough to get both k4 and k-27 signals
at these sites networks for different
pieces however does not work for a T
which segments that means this is really
specific to CPG Islands many lamps have
observed similar things and just to
highlight one more story here from the
Bert lab you can also take this a step
further and look at fully synthetic and
artificial CPG islands that are devoid
again of transcriptional of known
transcriptional regulatory elements and
signatures and again we're introducing
these artificial CPG atoms into cell
lines that proved sufficient to get both
K 4 NK 27 trimethylation
and besides
this also highlights another important
aspect of recruitment of these sectors
that one is DNA methylation an important
prerequisite for CPG Islands to act as
recruitment platforms for both K 4 and K
27 trimethylation is the absence of DNA
methylation
let us lessons in illustrated in this
experiment here in a CPG Island or in a
in a stretch of DNA that has very high
CPG contents of the dinucleotide
sequence is very much a wish but the
overall content of G and C nucleotides
is very low we do not get better than
domains we have no k4 trimethylation and
no k-27 for methylation and the reason
for that is that these sequences get DNA
methylated so we clearly need the
absence of DNA methylation and the
presence of CPG Islands to get beveled
domains another important point is the
role of transcription and the team
around that Burnstein they did something
very clever here in one of the initial
papers they found a CPG Island that is
shared by two genes and all of these
genes in its promoter has a lot of
annotated transcription factor binding
zones so what they did was they split
the CPG Island in half and then looked
at the chromatin state of each half if
you look at the site that does not have
been relatives we again get a variant
domain it has gold k4 trimethylation and
k-27 prior methylation however the side
that has the binding factor site this
one gets only k4 trimethylation but no
k-27 trimethylation
presumably because the transcription
factors that would bind these sites are
present in the cell
abiding to it and activating the genes
that are associated with it in this way
preventing the establishment of bivalent
domains and this was shown also more
recently by the lab of Christine helling
where they looked at this in a more
genome-wide scale what they did was they
used two small molecules Gav and trip
delayed to inhibit transcription and in
this snapshot here for the mixing you
can see that in the absence of these you
have presence of RNA polymerase 2
meaning there's active transcription
going on and after a few hours with
these inhibitors the whole pole 2 signal
is gone meaning transcript
shut down conversely we observe rapid
recruitment of members of the
polycomb-group
complex PSC - so the SUNY 12 supplement
occurs at the site that last
transcription and at the same time we
also get k-27 trimethylation and again
all these sides that were gained in this
way they all overlap with CPG Islands so
this is not something that happens at
other places but again we need CPG
Island and all these sites that they
observed in this way they all confirm or
overlap with known PSU - binding sites
from other cellular systems so this
nicely shows that we need CPG Islands we
need the absence of DNA methylation and
the absence of active transcription to
get the feminine domain and we can
summarize this here
so ed of event locus we have recruitment
of both the complexes that introduce the
active mark said one and ever our
complexes but also repressive complexes
like PSC - and it's brother PFC one and
bivalent domain - they're both present
and set up both k4 and k-27
trimethylation at an active site what we
will observe is that we will loose we
will have robust k4 trimethylation and
in this way for example PSU to cannot
modify its neutral zones and in this way
these sites will remain active how each
of these states is being set up in the
first place is still a little bit of a
mystery what could happen is that we
have a priming event that we first get
k4 trimethylation which then gets
reinforced if there's active
transcription or it won't be partially
removed if there's no active
transcription and then we get
establishment off by metal domains so we
know CPG Islands are very important for
this but how is this translated in
mechanistic terms for that I would like
to talk a little bit about the
recruitment mechanisms of ponycorn and
tread boards genes and I would just like
to hide it a few principles because as
you can already see from this finger
here there's a lot of different
interactions and a lot of factors
involved with that but let's see how
these connect to CPG Islands here we
have our model CPG Island and it's been
recognized by these
succeed domains CXC domains approaching
domains that bind cpg which DNA that is
devoid of DNA methylation and this way
their ideal recruitment mechanisms to
combine to recruit proteins to CPG
islands and ml 1 and M L 2 they have a
CPG Islands they handle c XX c domain as
part of the protein itself whereas in
the sent one complexes they rely on an
auxiliary subunits EF p 151 likewise
associate sexy domain and ever includes
these complexes to CPG Islands another
important aspect of this recruitment is
also true for many other chromatin
modifiers it's a positive feedback loop
so CFP one also has a PhD finger domain
which binds k4 trimethylation there by
the complex recognizes its own mark once
the markets there the complex will have
a higher incentive to stay there and
propagate or stabilize the mark and the
same principles also apply to the
impressive complexes where we have PSU
to up here and the pse one context is
down here and again CPG Islands are very
important for their recruitment so for
PSE - that is still a little bit of an
open question because none of the CPSU -
something's have a direct binding domain
for CPG Islands this gyro - subunit here
and some binding affinity for GC with
DNA in the hands of Sun but not of
others
now non-coding RNAs may also play a role
in recruitment of pso2 and one idea is
that they derive from CPG which regions
and they form stem loops on the RNA
level which are then recognized by a
binding site on PSC - however in the
case of PSC one these things are more
straightforward because here again we
have a protein that has a CPG that has a
C xxe domain and that is KTM to B this
is a demethylase which is part of some
PFC one complexes but not others so PSC
one subsumes a lot of different
complexes which actually probably should
be called by a different name because
they are very different they share a few
supplements but they do very different
things and one class of these have
to be succulent it's also part of other
complexes it might also directly
interact with PSC - and thereby also
mediate recruitment to CPG Islands other
PFC one complexes do not have KDM to be
but they bind so-called cbx proteins and
these find k-27 flour methylation and
again we have a similar positive
feedback group these complexes bind k-27
trimethylation that are being recruited
to these sites and thereby propagate the
repressor signal in Alton PMC to has a
binding site for its own mark and that
is located on the eg subunit edy can
bind PFF the inactive mark k-27
translation they've also stabilized
recruitment off the PSU to complex these
few z1 complex with rather than half KTM
to be they do not bind k-27
trimethylation
that they have enzymatic activity which
they place h2 a ubiquitination this mark
is in turn recognised as we now know by
the PFC to complex when this way a POC -
can also be localized again to CPG
Islands by nez perce e1 complexes I
would just like to highlight one of many
papers that recently came out on this
topic because it elegantly shows how
this equipment works but the clothes lab
has done is they tailored one of the
subunits of the so called variant PSC
one complexes which are the ones that
place H to be your cue to nation to a
specific site and the genome and then
they observe the chromatin state at this
site at the site they observe
recruitment of their construct and also
recruitment of other complex members in
this case women B which then places the
edge-to-edge recruiter nation because
it's an active conformation in this
variant pic1 complexes and this alone is
sufficient to also recruit easy H to
Susie 12 and get installation of K 27
trimethylation
that's however is not the case if one of
these so-called classical complex is
being recruited where we again get
remotely but not in an extra state there
is no age to be your nation and no
recruitment of PN C - so there's a lot
of different mutual interactions going
on one of them is that PSU - places
twenty-seven trimethylation stabilizes
its own recruitment but also recruits
the so called canonical PSU one
complexes which have these CB x subunits
in addition the varying PFC one
complexes can be recruited to CPG
Islands put age to obtain ubiquitination
which then in turn is recognized for PFC
to so in any case we have recognition of
CPG Islands and a lot of positive
feedback goals so just to summarize this
again we now have a broad understanding
of how these complexes are being
recruited to CPG Islands and how they
stabilize their own binding there
however the question is what are the
marks and these complex is actually
doing there in order to mediate poising
and there's a few theories out there of
how this might happen and all these many
of these circle around the CPG Islands
on a molecular level we know CX x e
domain containing proteins are being
recruited to CPG items what happens
there is if we have active transcription
only the active factors of being bound
and the polycomb complexes cannot bind
and the fully repressed state we have
the opposite the polycomb context is
signed and presumably don't allow the
active complexes to bind and in this way
we end up with a bi-stable switch
together with these positive feedback
loops we can go from a repress state to
an active state the bivalent means
however sit somewhere in between of this
they kind of convert this model to
retrieve stable or try stable model
whereby Velen domains have an
equilibrium between the progressives and
the active factors and there were
neither fully active normally repressed
but combining of other repressive
factors for instance and loss of active
factors like most importantly the
transcription factors they can go to a
fully repressed state alternatively
binding of more active factors can
convert them to a fully active state and
remove binding of these repressive
factors what could be the purpose of
that why do we need this intermediate
state one reason could be that this
allows to fine-tune gene expression
during the
development what that means is the
following if we have the stubborn in
state where we have both active and
progressive input this might find human
calibrate gene expression so that at a
specific threshold for expression or
signal we get the right amount of
expression of this protein at derive
developmental time what could happen is
if we have a fully repressed state yes
it will be possible to activate these
genes if we have strong transcription
factors but it might take too much
effort in too much signal so the time
when the gene was supposed to come on
could be missed during differentiation
because it's just too difficult to
activate the gene on the contrast if you
don't have any modification these genes
might be susceptible to more noise in
might be turning on too easily
and last but not least in the case of
housekeeping genes these should not be
able to be regulated at all because they
would fully be in an active State the
whole time so how can we test these
models how can we really see what
Bavarian domains are doing for gene
expression or one way of doing that is
by knocking out the factors that
introduce the villain domains and this
in fact has been done in many cases for
supplements of the PSC to complex PS e1
conflicts and also for their tri-powered
complexes what we observe is that most
of these as I indicated in the beginning
have developmental defects in animals
and they are often every are neutral in
embryonic stem cells that need to defect
and differentiation so that means these
complexes clearly have a role in
development however they are active at
many different sites in the genome and I
just show the snapshot here to
illustrate that we have k4
trimethylation obviously also at active
genes not only at Bavarian genes but
they're also k-27 trimethylation spends
broad regions of the genome so reduce
these complexes it's very difficult to
pinpoint whether the consequence that we
observe are specific for evident domains
there's one enzyme where we can do that
however that is ml to both the chalant
account and the Stewart labs they have
done experiments with ml to knock out
cell lines what they nicely showed is
that if you get rid of ml 2 you lose k4
trimethylation
almost exclusively
Advent domain so this is the enzyme that
stays in k4 trimethylation and pudendal
domains and again these are all
developmentally regulated genes and the
ones that lose k4 trimethylation the
most are one that have been classified
as bivalent so what they did was after
knocking down this enzyme is to look at
gene expression during differentiation
and they use the system that many people
use which is based on retinoic acid for
differentiation and as you can see here
it's not an awful lot of difference in
gene expression profiles between the
control cells and them all to knockout
cells that also carries forward in
different ways of analysis and also by
looking at closer time points for a few
genes they did not see much of the
difference so at face value that
probably that could tell us that we do
not need the vivarium configuration in
order to parse genes for expression
because during differentiation they will
come on in just the same way however
this vessel mooing acid-based
differentiation system may not be an
accurate reflection of what is going on
in the embryo so it might be required
and will definitely be required to test
other differentiation systems as well
and see whether their defect of ml 2
loss lll to loss has been characterized
in stem cells and also in whole amber in
the whole animals and again loss of ml
to is methyl so there clearly is a
developmental role for this protein and
presumably given that it's only active
evident domains we could expect that its
developmental phenotype depends on
lebanon domains but again this still
remains to be tested in the test tube
and bring in further data to fully
analyze this in addition to knockout
models there's other also other
approaches of how we can get a better
feel of the physiological importance of
prevalent domains just to introduce one
of these novel techniques we could use
for that I would like to talk a little
bit about single cell transcriptomics so
there's plenty of methods out there
right now to sit in to isolate single
cells and then analyze the mRNA content
and sequence that and the Aachen lab for
example has done that for embryonic stem
cell cultures and Sarah
we remind you several conditions and
ones where things are more fluctuating
and the cells are not all in a
homogeneous state however what they
observed is that the intersection
between the jeans to the most variable
and Beavan domains is very high and also
lots of developmental teams are among
the most variable genes either the one
to the most constantly expressed in show
police variation they very rarely
overlap with parental domains so this
could be support for the idea that
bivalent domains leave enough wiggle
room so say for these dreams to become
activated when there is the right amount
of stimulus around and already in CERN
there are a lot of stimuli a lot of
input for these cells signaling so this
might be an indication that indeed
they're having a vivarium configuration
we get variation and allow these genes
to be activated more rapidly more
visible but again this is just one
approach and there many others out there
that I will not touch upon today but
just to summarize there's still a lot of
work to do on bi-metal domains even
though we know that they exist we now
have a good feeling for how they look
like
they have both k4 and k-27 cly
methylation together in this isometric
configuration we know how they can be
established and we learned a lot along
the way about how these enzymes are
recruited their placements modifications
but still it's an open question whether
they are really physiologically
important in whether they contribute to
poisoning and more importantly if they
do so how they do that and with that I
would like to close thank you all very
much for your attention and I would like
to hand over to Sharon Thank You Philips
thank you very much for a great talk
here I'd like to tell you about some of
the products and tools that we have that
can help with your histone research many
of you will be aware of our epigenetics
range of products we have several
antibodies to study histone bilayer
domains researches tell us that our
antibodies are the gold standard in
their research two key antibodies
against modified histones in Bavarian
domains
or histone h3 primary cell k4 antibody a
B eight five eight zero which has over
400 citations and our histone h3 charm
SLK 27 antibody a b6 0 0 2 which has
have over 105 patients in addition our
unmodified histone antibody histone h3
antibody a b-17 line 1 has over 800
citations of course these histone and
what is our chip grades and have been
tested in chips you can find out how
other researchers have used these
antibodies by looking at the
publication's listed on each of the
product datasheets
on our website of course
chip is the key technique in the study
of bivalent domains so you may be
interested in our high sensitivity chip
kit a B one eight five nine one three we
have optimized this kit to work with low
cell numbers only two thousand cells are
required we recommend this kit when you
are working with proteins that is
expressed at low level such as
transcription factors where you need
maximum sensitivity with minimal
nonspecific background signal with a
flexible 96-well plate format you can
carry out either single preparations or
multiple preparations at the same time
this kit has a simple protocol that
takes you from chromatin extraction to
DNA recovery in only 5 hours with
extract that is ready to use in a
variety of downstream applications such
as chips pcr chip on chip and chip SEC
if you want to prepare a library for
next-generation sequencing then you may
want to use our chips sake high
sensitivity kit a be one eight five nine
zero eight the optimized protocol allows
you to construct single Plex and
multiplex chip set libraries with
reduced bias if you are interested in
studying mechanistic aspects of histone
methyl transferase and demethylase we
offer a number of kit to
enzyme activity these kids give
sensitive quantitative detection without
the need for radioactivity these assays
rely on antibody detection of substrate
and can be used with nuclear extracts
from cells and tissues as well as
purified proteins all our activity kits
work in a convenient microplate format
with options for color metric or for
metric me doubt within three hours we
find that good sample preparation is the
key to getting good data if you want to
ensure reproducible preparation of your
extract we offer a range of sample
preparation kit these include whole cell
extraction nuclear extraction nuclear
extractions and nucleic acid free
Crampton extraction and histone
extraction kits as you can see most kits
can be used with those cells and tissues
with a preparation of time of less than
one hour if you would like to find out
more please visit our webpage on methods
and tools to study histone modifications
we have many resources around
epigenetics on our website
our chip resources include a
cross-linking chip protocol a
troubleshooting guide and free on-demand
webinars including one that takes you
through chips chips step by step and
another chips X data analysis in
addition we have a section dedicated to
histones where you can find guides to
what histone modifications do and the
methods available to study them as well
as links to related products for histone
modification research you may be
interested in a conference that we have
coming up in two Almina
in sicily from the 2nd of November to
the 4th of November talking about coding
and non-coding functions of the genome
Clemmie construct structure in stem
cells genome architecture and human
disease we hope to see you there if you
want to keep up to date with new
products webinars and other events
please register
cama calm forward slash register
and the first question from one of our
participants is related to a paper by
Peter Jones on bivalent regions of
cytosine methylation and h3k27
acetylation suggests an active role for
DNA methylation at enhancers so the
question is can you please comment on
the by valency of h3k27 a C and D DNA
methylation around active enhancers why
do active enhancers have DNA methylation
yes so that is a very good question
there was a very excellent paper that
recently came out and so that gives us
one important point as well there's
different flavors of balancing there's
many different things that people now
refer to as stability keeping it very
general in the sense of one marker
occurring with another and calling them
by valency so then can mean the same
thing as the classical prevailing
domains that we have at the Lotus but it
can also mean different things in this
case it kind of means a little bit
something different so enhancers are a
very important place of gene regulation
as well
however they underline different roles
different different rules of regulation
and of course it is very surprising to
see DNA methylation which is correct and
commonly assumed to be a repressive
model and an active enhancer so DNA
methylation depending on where it is in
the genome can have many different
functions the interesting point is
however that the enzymes involved in
making the effort elation at these
active enhancers and apparently not
sensitive to DNA methylation so having
DNA methylation presence does not
prevent k27 acetylation from happening
that means that the enzymes involved do
not have any c XX c domain so this is
different from the CPG ion regulation
but yet again we also find PFC to add
enhancers that these are either poised
or inactive at the exercise may be the
DNA methylation actually helps to remove
the repressive complexes as neurotoxic
ly s apply themselves and then we have a
pipe
on state soccer permanency that has k27
acetylation empty and a methylation at
the same time and I hope that answers
the question Thank You Phillips that's
great I have another question here for
you considering the case of bivariate
domains for example h3k27 AC and h3k27
me3 desire circulation at h3k27 mean
lower trimethylation
at h3k27 on the same refugee how can
this be tested yes there is an excellent
question as well so there are also sites
that have both k27 acetylation in k-27
trimethylation in our mass spectrometry
analysis or neutral zones that have k-27
trimethylation we only observe very few
of these but so this is one of the ways
that how this can be tested by doing
mass spectrometry on Singham loop
systems where we can see that the
enrichment of k-27 trimethylation leads
to a decrease in k27 acetylation so by
default because these modifications at
the same site they cannot be on the same
histone they could still be on the same
luc besson and d single molecule also a
resins paper that i mentioned from the
branch in that they actually looked at
exactly that and described ways to
analyze this combination of
modifications and they did observe if i
remember correctly a little bit of
overlap like we did in the mass
spectrometry but yes there's definitely
ways of testing that both football
chromatin just to see whether these
modifications were linked or occur or
not and for specific both sides by using
these single module approaches a cupcake
thank you okay we have another question
okay so bivalent domains are defined as
the co-occurrence of h3k27 m e & h3k4me3
however are there other marks present
alongside these two at their valence
domains what do we know about these so
yeah that's a very common question as
well obviously
there's a lot of different histone
modifications occurring at the same
place at the same time which we know for
mass spectrometry studies but also for
chip stick studies and yes presume most
likely these covalent domains not only
have k-27 chemical ation and k4
trimethylation but also other marks one
example is the h2 b of the protonation
h-2a ubiquitination which is placed by
the variant p SE volume of texas and
it's very likely probably that de sites
also have acetylation and active
residues for example k-9s insulation but
this is the field that we don't fully
understand yet but again it points at
the fact that we need to look at
combinations of histone marks and
Bevelle domains our prime example for
such combinations thank you for that we
have another question here in the main
paper there are roughly four 1405
valence in differentiated cells recent
papers also focused on by valency in
adult in testin testin tissues and
includes two what their role could be
yeah that's also very interesting
question that also often comes up in
discussions about balancing yes they'd
most likely have a role in developments
or tissues and itself that can still
differentiate and thereby their genes
that need to be kept in a state that can
still be activated
however yes we also see them in more
terminally differentiated cells and yes
it is a question of what they're doing
there are they actually doing something
there were other just a remnant of
differentiation so one idea about this
is that they could just be remnants in
the sense that these genes the cell
never had to make a decision about them
in the sense of whether they really need
to be turned on or turn off and they
just remain in this paradigm state and
presumably these cells that they're in
fate will not express the transcription
factors that are needed to activate this
gene so there might be no need to shut
them down completely on the other hand
maybe they still retain some sort of
pasta or maintain some sort of
participate for these cells that may be
under very rare instances that we have
no clue about at this point these jeans
might still become activated for
whatever reason but yeah that's highly
speculative and we don't know about that
so my guess would be they're just
randoms that had never had the
requirement to before you shut down
that's great
thank you okay the next question is
bivalent domains are found at CPG rich
promoters how far do bivalent domains
stretch do they cover the whole promoter
or just specific regions of it yeah
that's a good question as well um so we
don't we don't fully know yet but
there's a lot of lipstick data out there
that covers this question and given that
the CPG Islands are recruiting both of
them at the metal translators for k4
trimethylation and for k-27
trimethylation it is to be expected that
along the whole length of the CPG Island
we should have both of these marks
present so as long as we have a CPG
Island within the CPG Island and closely
around it we will have these two marks
coming together great thank you for it
the next question is in ES cells we also
have poised enhancers could they
function in similar ways is bivalent
domains their promoters yeah that is
definitely a possibility so we don't
really know yet how poised enhancers are
regulated but some of the same players
show up there as well so we also have
the PFC to complex and the k-27
trimethylation mark sitting at these
enhancers and it is reasonable to assume
that they might have similar functions
there as at the bivalent promoters but
we don't fully know the answer to this
just yet
okay moving on to the next question the
definition of bivariate domain hinges on
the co-occurrence of h3k4me3 and h3k27
Emmie however based on chipset data we
cannot really be sure whether promoter
is bivalent or not should you do reach
it whenever you want to be certain that
a focus Lucas is bivalent or are there
alternatives
yeah that's obviously a very good
question so just from doing separate
gypsy grunts it will never be fully
possible to ascertain whether a gene is
really available or not unless don't ask
the region and put that obviously what
is the gold standard but it's very
difficult at least nobody has support
yet to do this in a genome-wide scale so
as soon as we have protocols for that
which would be great to have that would
be could become more of a standard si to
test that we do the reach it and then to
analyze the sanno genome-wide scale then
we know which of the genes that Rudy
bivalent which ones aren't
but in general another way of test of
narrowing down the probability of
something being truly by vendors they're
just looking at the competition of the
promoter if we have a strong CPG Islands
and we are in a tissue where we have a
lot of pac-2 activity then the
likelihood is very high that these are
actually by males because all all the
signs are there or the hallmarks of
recruitment and off setting up the
structure are there and then they are
very likely to probably be by the end
great thank you again so we have another
question CPG Islands obviously play an
important role in the recruitment of
polycomb complexes however in flies
there are the so-called polycomb
response elements that mediate
recruitment of these complexes do PR es
exist in mammalian cells as well yeah
there is also a very good question
so yeah in flies there are these
sequence elements that mediate
recruitment
but in mammals people have tried to
identify them and there have been many
papers that proposed PR es they might be
droopy IES in the sense of they mediate
recruitment and that the results
definitely show that however often the
common denominator of these sequences is
that they are CPG image so they might
just be CPG items in disguise whether
they are still additional elements
additional sequences that mediate
equipment of psv complexes PFC to in
especially we don't know that yet so
there might still be PS out there which
are not CPG Islands and yeah this
remains to be seen thank you for it